hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the US Championship 2019
it's Samuel Franklin versus Jeffrey's
young and Samuel Franklin as you most
probably know won the US Championship
2018 last year and he wanted a half a
point ahead of Fabiano Caruana without a
single loss and the two full points
ahead of Wesley sole which is you know
that's that's as good as it gets
so here this is a game from around 3:00
he faces his younger adversary Jeffrey's
young and it's really really an
impressive game definitely a saturday
saturday improver I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy it so without further ado let's
check out this very nice game it's a
twelve player round-robin
everyone's gonna face off against
everyone they're facing off for a
hundred and ninety four thousand dollars
so not you know not not a bad
compensation for playing chess and also
it's a normal classical time control
tournament hour and a half for the first
40 moves then additional time and time
increment 30 seconds per move starting
from one so all pretty standard now
without further ado definitely let's
check out this very nice game Shanklin
has the white pieces and he opens with E
4 we have e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and now well can't really remember when
was the last time we've shown a game
where the Scotch was played maybe cuz
power versus Wesley soul or or something
like that from the from the ultimate
blitz challenge but maybe even after
that something can't really remember but
ok he captures standard line the knife
captures on before and now Queen to f6
offering if white wants to go into this
fancy line with nice captures on c6 and
Bishop to c5 were black would threaten
checkmate
and after white defends let's say
between f3 then you would play D
captures and the game continues as
follows but this is very comfortable for
black White has different ideas here
Shanklin goes for Knight to b3 and we
have Queen to g6 by Geoffrey attacking
the e4 pawn but also pressuring the g2
point it's somewhat difficult for white
to develop the light square bishop so
here fixing all the problems we have f3
preparing to develop the king and f2 as
you'll see in the game we have nice to
f6 here or this position has been played
in 2016 in the Baku Azerbaijan chess
olympiad other moves issue head this
position against Antonia Stefano was the
final play d5 here and the mothership
was able to win this game but here we
have nice to have six by Shion Bush up
to F sorry that's not a bishop bishop to
f4 and now Bishop to b4 check and here
black is asking why do you want to play
c3 I'm just gonna move back and then
you're well you have opponents e3 maybe
you're gonna have to develop the knight
via d2 worse then I'm gonna go from d2
and it's definitely playable but here
white doesn't want to waste time here
Shanklin goes for King - f - you know
moves moves with tempo so to say now
he's ready to develop his a light square
bishop will bring the rook into the game
after the bishop moves from there and
sort of castle artificially okay
Shion goes castles with a three now
forcing the bishop back via a3 not c3
bishop goes to e seven and now Bishop to
d3 and here white is ready to bring the
rook into the game and hide the king we
have nice to h5 pressuring this bishop
on f4 and here or you could go back push
up to g3 but there's also this
opportunity for grabbing the c7 point
and Shanklin does not want to back down
from a challenge so he decides to grab
the pawn with Bishop captures on c7 and
now d6 for the moment trapping this
Bishop and c7 it's not really going
anywhere this is covered by the pawn
this is covered by the night so you did
grab a pawn but for the moment your
Bishop is out of game now and here we
have E 5 just trying to bust open as
white of course wants to bring his
official back into the game
with Bishop to h4 width check now when
played when Han who played a 5 he also
Unleashed Unleashed this discovery
towards the black king a queen and here
what do you do your king is in check so
you do obviously have the option of
playing g3 or you could move the king
now g3 is a very nice nice idea but it
really favors white sort of black as
after Bishop CalPERS here you will
capture and after Queen captures for
example King goes here neither for check
King to d2 and now comes the night
capture Sun d3c captors and after Queen
captures only five it's hard hard to see
how you will get this Bishop out of
there Queen to e7 is coming and also
your your King is just looking very
silly indeed to once black starts
developing it will be a very tough
position to defend all right well it was
possible to go for this but Shanklin
decided it was too risky so he decided
to go for King to f1 which you know it's
definitely a concession now your your
rook is stuck on h1 you're not getting
getting to develop it which is a shame
and here we have Queen to h6 a very nice
move getting out of getting out of the
attack but also I know you constantly
have to keep an eye let's say Queen III
could be a very nice idea if white will
not be able to defend it but okay here
we have e captures and e6 young allows
even this creates allows white to create
a powerful past the D pawn already on d6
we have looked yet
now with ideas of rook to e1 check or or
maybe not because we have Knight to c3
by white and here you could grab the
Queen for example rook e1 check when
capture special captures rook captures
and then your I don't know it seems like
you would prefer white here I mean you
do have a passed pawn on d6 once now you
will definitely be able to play king of
to get the rook into the game and well
it definitely seems like white is the
one to prefer here so after Knight to c3
machine goes for Knight to e5 and okay
now there are a whole lot of pieces here
in front of the black King you
definitely want to improve your position
and here nice the c5 was played which is
well which is a bold move
d7 will be threatened if this Knight
moves but Knights the e4 should have
been played it would it would bring yet
another defender closer to the white
king here Knight the c5 is played and
now it well black is just
fast so feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out Black's plan
here I'll just give you a couple of
seconds while I have a nice sip of water
here for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent you know a tempter of
overnight sacrifice and for those who
just want to enjoy the show the movies
night captures on f3 and now it's pretty
obvious you cannot capture with the Jeep
one because then Bishop to h2 check King
G one Queen III will be checkmate the
bishop controls this diagonal and if the
Queen captures it's not much better then
rook to e3 is the idea now the Queen has
to move let's say go Queen d1 now just
Queen to f4 this is check in g1 now
Queen 2 F 2 will be checkmate
so this Knight captures an f3 you cannot
capture tonight you have to figure out
what to play we have night Knight 3 to F
or bringing yet another defender closer
to the King also closing off the e-file
but now we have Bishop to g4 by black
there was a there was a very interesting
line but it's a it's it's a long engine
line it's well impossible for humans to
play it but I will show it as it's very
interesting the move f5 and now whatever
you do let's say Queen captures on f3
you grab a piece F captures on e4 Bishop
captures on e4 and now Knight to f6 with
with a double attack on the bishop here
and after d7 white wants to get the
bishop back into the game Bishop
captures Bishop to f4 now attacking the
Queen and Bishop to g5 blocking Bishop
d5 check King to h8 and now Knight
captures on d7 Knight captures Bishop
captures on g5 and Queen captures and g5
and you would have this position our the
material is completely equal it's a
bishop against tonight but of course
black is the to be preferred here this
rook is still undeveloped once once
black develops both of the rooks it will
be very hard to play roof to f8 a huge
threat
white will not be able to untangle here
but like I said a very long engine line
this F I move hard to hard to imagine
and Jeffrey would play it but okay we
have brush up to g4 here and now comes
d7 and now rook the e5 so it's amazing
how white allows this pawn to come all
the way to d7 but the bishops do a very
nice job of preventing the point from
reaching the destination and here we
have Bishop captures on e5 white accepts
the rook why the move you could also
play is Queen to c1 but it's also a very
complicated line because now after nice
the d2 check you get Queen captures
Queen captures Knight captures on d2 and
now rook captures on c5 and after you
promote to a queen Bishop captures
Bishop captures rook captures and you
would have this position where it's it's
a it's it's a playable position the
material is equal but still before white
a man manages to develop this rook on h1
it will be a slightly better position
for black so here after Luke to e5 a
very complicated move the screen to c1
Shanklin decides to grab the exchange
with Bishop characters on e5 Knight
captures on e5 now opening up a
discovery against the White Queen Queen
to d2 offering a queen queen trade now
and here Queen to c6 avoiding the Queen
trade and now h3 just trying to get rid
of this Bishop with Bishop captures on
b7 finally getting rid of this past pawn
nice captures Knight captures and now
Queen to c3
and here shengcún is hoping for Queen
captures and after Knight captures he
even wants to give back the exchange
because this rook really isn't doing
anything after a 93 check King g1 might
capture screen captures let's say
Marshall goes back we would have this
endgame again with a completely equal
material bishops would be of opposite
color you know it's still a game but
after Queen to c3 we have Queen to h6
Jeffery again avoids the trade of Queens
as well his opponent's king is on f1 the
rope is still out of play you do not
want to trade Queens here and here again
a very complicated position what you
want to play is g3
and well now you
want to capture with the night because
you want your opponent to capture and
then you capture with the night
delivering check but now you get Bishop
to e2 opening up a discovered attack
towards Ono attacking the night and
opening up an attack towards the bishop
so the threat is remove the defender and
grab the bishop here and after Bishop to
e5 attacking the Queen Queen to f3 with
a double attack on the knight Knight to
f4 and now comes rotate to d1 this was a
White's best possible sequence of moves
to try and get back into the game but
here Shanklin after Queen to h6 played
g4 and now there's a problem here
well it's it's an interesting position
just you don't have to find a winning
move or anything just try and pause just
for a bit and see what you would play
here just as a you know to see how you
stand here in this position Geoffrey
played f5 which which is an excellent
move but there is a there's a move that
two wins on the spot it would seem but
both of them seems to have missed it
after Queen to f4 check now after King
to e2
Knight d2 f6 bringing the knight in the
game with a double attack against this
efore night and also threatening to
bring the rook into the game and now it
depends if you play something like nice
captures on f6 you get Bishop captures
and now this comes with an attack on the
Queen White has to react to this and
after you move the Queen now comes nice
to g3 check you just have to move the
King in d1 now you get Queen to f3 check
you will pick up the rook and whatever
whitey does your just simply up too much
material in a completely winning
position and on the other hand after
this Queen to f4 check King e2 if you go
Knight 2 D 2 F 6 and now white it
doesn't capture but rather immediately
attempts a queen trade now just play
Knight captures here and after Queen
captures you get Knight captures with
check King III now I get Knight capture
son d 3c captures and knights the c5
black has a bishop and the night for a
rook which will with it with an equal
amount of points but it should the
result in a winning endgame for black
but okay it's Hart hard to decide for
for such a
align better is f5 here hoping that if G
captures here then you get this F
captures on e4 where you open up the F
file for your rook Shanklin of course is
not interested in that he decides to go
G captures on f5 just closing the F file
and not rook to e8 by Geoffrey I just
ring that rook into the game again
cutting off the King away from from the
left side of the board we have Queen to
c4 check King to h8 and now rook to g1
so it's it's amazing how Shang wants
King is on on f1 wide open and he's the
one that that is attacking but here it
doesn't work so now really feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for black I will give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
threatener of checkmates with the Queen
on e3 and for those who who just want to
enjoyed short quinta III now a dangerous
idea rook captures here would be would
be very deadly as it removes the
defender of the f2 Square where he would
just deliver check mate with the Queen
so here we have looked the g2 defending
the f2 square and now comes Knight to f4
attacking the rook rook to h2 and now
bishop the g3 is a possibility but
Geoffrey goes for knife captures on h3
we have King to g2 now threatening to
capture the knight Knight back to a4
check King to h1 and now Queen to f3
check King to g1 we have Queen to g4
check King to h1 and now Queen to f3
check Geoffrey repeats the position to
move closer to the time control we have
kink the g1 and now how do you continue
the attack everything is you know
perfectly placed feel free to pause the
video once again and try to try to find
the continuation it's such a wild game
you can always you know just try and
continue to attack more for the Duke
were able to do it - congratulations
especially if you solved the first two
you are truly an excellent player and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show Bishop to d8
now you can see that the king is on a
nice dark square the queen controls all
of the other squares there's a there's
really no defense against Bishop to
Bishop to b6 here Shanklin tried rook to
f1 to take care of the f2 square with
Bishop to b6 check now Knight blocks and
now Queen to g3 with chip King to h1 now
comes Queen to f3 check King to g1 and
now Knight to h3 check forcing Blackduck
a forcing white to capture and we have
rook captures and Queen captures the
knight cannot capture of course as it's
still pinned by the bishop with Queen to
f4 trying to bring yet another defender
to the defense but it doesn't work here
well before before the Queen came to a4
you could imagine something like 95
followed by Knight f3 is the game over
so here whites at White's idea is Queen
a4 and now if 95 go Bishop e2 to cover
the f3 squared this way how about
Geoffrey just uses the f6 square instead
we have Bishop to b5 now attacking the
rook and now again it's it's just a
forcing sequence briefly pause the video
here and try to find the winning idea
for black yet again as white white is a
resilient defender so the attack simply
continues I will just have another nice
sip of water for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you have
finally solved this game and for those
who just wanna enjoy the show rook to e4
like we said the knight is still pinned
and the Queen has nowhere to go once
once the Queen moves rook to g4 will be
deadly
and if you go sounds like Queen v8 check
Knight will block still there's no way
to defend it you can go go should be to
block it this way but then black just
doesn't even capture black just place
nice to h4 and now you have to just keep
keep giving up material to prolong the
game which makes no sense you can just
play any move and then Queen to h1
welcome as a checkmate and well there's
the knight on f2 still pinned by the
bishop on b6 and I will also use this as
a thumbnail as its is just a very nice
nice position but yeah after this
rook to e4 move Samuel Franklin resigned
and a tough loss especially with the
white pieces but it's still early in the
tournament so but I mean yeah last year
he he finished a halfway point ahead of
a biancalana without a single loss and I
already suffers a loss in round 3
definitely I mean it can't feel good but
you know it's just anything can happen
so we'll see how the tournament will
turn up for him and we're gonna cover a
bit more games from the championship and
then we're gonna show the standings and
such but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that it improved your
Saturday it surely improved mine it's a
really a wonderful game a long time
since I've seen such a such an
action-packed game I would like to thank
Andres Martin Alexander Dubinsky
Dubinsky Martin car Wesley Cassidy and
Remy youris for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
with some more interesting content
hopefully maybe some games from here
checking up on your suggestions and of
course continuing the Capablanca saga
thank you all I have an excellent rest
of your Saturday and I will see you soon